[Música]
boa tarde
olha é uma alegria imensa e queria dizer
pra vocês que eu não acredito em
coincidências a minha vida sempre foi
pautada por sincronicidades e quando o
meu querido amigo victor me anunciou que
nós teríamos esse balé das cadeiras de
rodas
eu não podia me furtar em começar esse
tópico para dizer pra vocês
com muita alegria que eu sou embaixador
honorário e amigo da aacd uma das mais
importantes instituições que cuidam das
pessoas com deficiência nesse país
nós temos aproximadamente sete pessoas
no brasil que nascem ou desenvolvem
algum tipo de deficiência seja ela
física ou neurológica ao longo da sua
vida
felizmente instituições como a cb tratam
muito bem com muito carinho com muita
competência dessas patologias mas nós
estamos aqui hoje porque o ted temos
longa que não sei se vocês sabem que
quer dizer ideias que merecem ser
compartilhadas
o que nós vimos aqui neste palco agora é
a grande ideia que tem que ser
compartilhada e mais do que isso
incorporada no nosso dia a dia para que
nós possamos nos lembrar os 94% 93% da
sociedade eo que felizmente não nasceram
com uma deficiência mas que
desenvolveram uma patologia que eu chamo
de coitadismo e que nos coloca como
reféns de cadeiras de rodas muletas
invisíveis e que nos fazem nos esconder
atrás do nosso conforto da nossa zona de
conforto para encontrar desculpas para
não realizar nossos sonhos para não
enfrentar as responsabilidades da nossa
vida
eu queria pedir a vocês mais uma salva
de palmas para essas pessoas que nos
fazem nos inspirar todos os dias
[Aplausos]
hoje é muito comum ouvir falar que temos
que acelerar e startups acelerar
empresas acelerar negócios para aumentar
a performance nossos negócios mas nós
esquecemos que atrás de qualquer startup
de qualquer negócio qualquer plano de
negócios mais bonito que possa parecer
estão pessoas e eu tenho dedicado grande
parte do meu tempo da minha vida hoje a
acelerar pessoas acelerar pessoas porque
eu amo as pessoas acredito no potencial
das pessoas mesmo quando elas próprias
não acreditam e é muito interessante
olhar eu há mais de 30 anos tem
convivido e vivido experimentado sucesso
eo insucesso também e tenho aprendido
que o sucesso não é uma casualidade mas
o fracasso também não é
eu brinco que eu digo o seguinte o cara
pra tá na merda tem que exercitar todo
dia a patologia do coitadismo e da
desculpa para não fazer bom
quero dizer para vocês que vou
aproveitar este palco para anunciar o
meu novo livro que é um guia antes
coitadismo está sendo lançado ninguém
fugido por acaso porque é verdade que
quero dizer que a vida faz uma grande
diferença com duas letras wars eo você
tem que escolher se você quer ser
fundido o que é ser fundido
essa é uma decisão que cabe a cada um de
assumir a responsabilidade sobre as suas
missões sobre as suas tarefas sobre os
seus projetos sobre seus sonhos e eu vim
aqui um pouco para compartilhar não da
minha biografia ou fazer uma apologia ao
sucesso mas pra utilizar essa trajetória
para chamar a atenção de algo que é
muito importante pra mim que essa
capacidade de acreditar de assumir
responsabilidades de fazer algo pra que
a minha vida seja especial
aos 53 anos de idade hoje eu me dedico
um projeto legado não pra deixar uma
herança simplesmente material pelo
sucesso que vem acumulando
mas para deixar um legado
de uma inspiração de exemplos de ética e
de alguém que tem uma visão que vai além
do meu sucesso
ponto.com do meu sucesso para acumular
riqueza mas o meu sucesso é a minha
felicidade de poder multiplicar este
sucesso olhando o sucesso dos outros
e essa história não aconteceu por acaso
e obviamente que eu não tinha a
habilidade genial de fazer milagres
empresariais mas eu aprendi muito cedo
na minha vida que eu tinha que
transformar as minhas limitações em
virtudes e foi assim rapidamente para
contar pra vocês que eu que era um
menino muito tímido que tinha problemas
seríssimos de fazer prova oral na escola
tive que encontrar nessa minha timidez o
início da minha carreira e quando eu ia
nas festinhas da minha escola eu tinha
um grande defeito que tem até hoje
graças a deus de pensar grande porque
está a pensar grande pequeno custo mesmo
então vamos pensar logo grande e eu
chegava na festa e eu tinha que tirar a
menina pra dançar
obviamente eu convidava a mais bonita
que obviamente esperava que o mais
bonito que disse ela para dançar então
já recebeu não só o ouro logo no começo
ficava deprimido treino vou chamar
nenhuma menina para dançar e assim eu me
aproximava da equipe de som do dj e
assim eu comecei a organizar as festas
da escola e eu entendi
eu aprendi que a autoestima é o grande
combustível para o nosso sucesso e eu
comecei a ser o quanto o dj mais legal
da escola e isso me criou uma confiança
para que eu pudesse superar as minhas
limitações sejam elas técnicas ou
intelectuais e isso me colocou dentro de
um cenário onde eu leio uma matéria numa
revista
depois de atuar como dj imagina que
maravilha essa criatura e eu vejo essa
revista francesa que trazia a história
fantástica da elite a maior agência de
modelos do mundo e eu olhei para aquilo
obviamente não entende nada por escrito
em francês não falava uma palavra de
francês
é mais ou menos como vocês vão ler a
caras só ver as caras e as bundas
obviamente e assim eu tomei uma decisão
naquele momento da minha vida que eu
iria me tornar sócio de sujeito chamado
john casablancas bom eu só tinha três de
pequenos problemas na minha vida não
falava uma palavra de inglês não tinha
um tostão e não conheço ninguém na
indústria da moda não existia internet e
não tinha com quem falar para pedir o
contato do homem e para fazer história
longa curta eu entrei numa trajetória de
poder não ver as dificuldades e poder
imaginar como sócio de sujeito e assim
eu me tornei carteiro de uma das grandes
empresas de transporte documentos a dhl
e fui a nova york dez vezes para então
poder propor a ele fazer negócio comigo
e assim essa trajetória me levou a
realmente acreditar que não existia
limites para os meus probleminhas
enfim os meus sonhos para as minhas
ambições e no dia 8 8 de 88 eu pude
viver a alegria e viver o sonho de olhos
bem abertos de quem podia realizar um
sonho que a maioria das pessoas me
diziam impossível
e quero dizer pra vocês o seguinte quem
destrói sonhos não são os seus inimigos
as pessoas que tem inveja de você são as
pessoas com quem você mais confia são
seus pais seu namorado ou namorada seu
marido sua esposa seu pastor na igreja e
esse é o grande perigo de você acreditar
na maior mentira do mundo que você não
pode fazer alguma coisa porque você não
tem dinheiro não tem amigos importantes
e não tem credenciamento para fazer
determinada coisa no dia 8 8 88 aquele
garoto que não tinha nenhuma idéia do
que acontecer lança a mais importante
agência de modelos do mundo que promove
as mais importantes modelos inclusive a
nossa querida gisele que é fruto dessa
equipe família de alguém que tinha tudo
para dar errado e acabou dando certo
só que isso não era suficiente e eu
estava em nova york na semana de moda
quando eu vejo uma campanha promovida
pelos mais importantes líderes da moda
americana e uma camiseta que tinha esse
símbolo no centro e eu perceba que se
trata entrou na loja do hof lorena que
na média um webmail e pergunta para
vendedor ela explica que aquela campanha
promovida estava sendo promovido pelos
mais importantes ícones da moda
americana com o objetivo de chamar a
atenção um problema gravíssimo que
atinge sete em cada dez mulheres nos
estados unidos que é o câncer de mama
eu pensei bom se isso acontece nos
estados unidos deixou entender
estatística no brasil encontra a
estatística é muito parecida no brasil e
decidido então que eu tinha que levantar
esta bandeira aqui no brasil por uma
causa tão relevante
eu tinha que aproveitar a minha condição
de líder na indústria para poder chamar
a atenção das mulheres brasileiras com
por duas camisetas roupas veio para o
brasil para blumenau falar com fábio
hering e propor desenvolver sua campanha
no brasil quando escutei várias objeções
dele pra que essa campanha não
acontecesse porque no brasil nós somos
um destino à campo da economia americana
e que isso seria um grande fiasco no
brasil e que eu ia me terminar com uma
conta para pagar
e eu disse meu amigo eu não vim
perguntar o que você acha da campanha eu
vou dizer pra você que eu vou fazer essa
campanha
ele falou mas querido depois não diga
que não te prevenir e disse meu amigo eu
vou fazer você me vendi a camiseta se
você pagar eu falei mas eu pedi a camisa
de graça então eu aprendi na minha
escola da vida que quando alguém quer
desencorajar a fazer alguma coisa ele
usa de argumentos espetaculares tão
rapidamente para dizer pra vocês que eu
tivesse escutado o maior especialista de
camisetas desse país
eu não poderia dizer pra vocês com
alegria que nós vendemos mais de 14
milhões de camisetas no brasil para
chamar a atenção de um problema
gravíssimo e que é a consciência da
mulher que por meio do auto exame pode
diminuir em 90% o índice de mortalidade
das mulheres por câncer de mama se isso
não é motivo de alegria se isso não é
motivo de orgulho se não é motivo de
você parar para pensar o que você está
fazendo pela vida das pessoas e qual o
seu papel na sociedade
se você de fato está assumindo a
responsabilidade como cidadão global e
que você se preocupa não só com a sua
vida com seu emprego com sua poupança
mas que se você se preocupa com o
bem-estar de outras pessoas
alguma coisa está muito errada na tua
vida e eu acho que essa é uma reflexão
importantíssima para que cada um de nós
saia daqui e pense o que nós podemos
fazer
ted x é um conceito global que adota as
cidades para compartilhar histórias cada
um de vocês
deveria ser um ted x de você mesmo que
tivesse histórias pra contar para seus
filhos por seus amigos por seus
colaboradores para os seus sócios que
pudessem fazer história para que você
possa de fato inspirar outras pessoas e
esse sujeito maravilhoso que obviamente
vocês deveriam imagino tenho grande
prazer de convidar em casa tomar um café
que é uma figura adorada né por
unanimidade no mundo mil por m cria uma
situação eu vou propor a ele um negócio
e esse negócio estava alinhado para
desenvolver um projecto imobiliário no
brasil e tinha uma expectativa muito
positiva e ele me convidou para uma
reunião depois de uma abordagem que eu
fiz a ele e quando chega no escritório
dele ele me diz de mau humor que eu
tinha só três minutos três minutos para
vender essa idéia pra ele aqui tem 18
minutos
imagina eu só tinha três e eu conseguir
efetivamente quebrar aquela objeção e
nós não só nos tornamos sócios que
fizemos grandes negócios no brasil mas
criamos uma história que foi publicada e
mais 14 países e eu aprendi uma outra
lição importantíssima em conta a grande
maioria joga pedra enquanto a grande
maioria sabe criticar não é o tranco
qualquer outra coisa eu posso tirar
proveito tirar ensinamentos e eu posso
aprender alguma coisa
o importante é a gente ter uma visão de
experiência
o labirinto é um lugar que você não sabe
onde está a saída mas não importa onde
está a saída do seu labirinto importa
você aproveitar cada passo dentro do
labirinto e aproveitar a experiência que
você acumula nesse processo da sua vida
isso pra mim é o grande ensinamento e
isso me fez entender que eu sou a minha
melhor marca
não é o cartão de visita marca instalar
o crachá que estou usando não sou eu é a
minha reputação que me antecede que me
precede é a minha forma de conduzir
minha vida minha ética de como fazer as
coisas e construir relacionamentos
porque são as pessoas que tomam
ações são as pessoas que fazem as coisas
acontecerem mas também são as pessoas
que encontram desculpas para que elas
não aconteçam
e é essa observação na vida que me faz
ter essa alegria de criar e desenvolver
desenvolver de reciclar as coisas e eu
vou um dia tomar um café em nova york na
loja nespresso e na minha xícara do lado
veio mais uma cápsula vazia e eu penso
vou fazer um projeto de arte meu país e
meu filho você inventa moda você pinta o
sete
bom eu reciclei 150 mil cápsulas de café
e cria uma coleção de arte que foi
exposta no soho nas mais importantes
galerias do mundo e doei todo este
acervo para importantes instituições
filantrópicas para chamar a atenção de
que a vida é conectar pontos
a vida é fazer com que as a sua
realidade possa ser transformada se você
acreditar em você mesmo e isso aconteceu
recentemente quando fui convidado para
fazer a conferência de encerramento no
rock in rio acaba em mim e eu que não
gosto de rock não frequenta o rock in
rio mas eu entendi que tinha uma
mensagem implícita muito importante que
eu queria concluir a minha participação
aqui com vocês para compartilhar com
vocês esse momento porque acho que ele é
fundamental e fiz isso no rock in rio
foi muito importante nós para sermos bem
sucedidos
temos que reconhecer que a felicidade
precede o sucesso e para ser feliz nós
temos que nos sentir protagonista das
nossas vidas nós temos que sentir que
nós temos controle das coisas que nós
fazemos nós temos que nos sentir lote
stars da nossa vida dos nossos negócios
mesmo que nós não saibamos como tocar
uma guitarra
eu fui provocado por um dos mais
importantes produtores musicais do
brasil um dos mais aclamados vencedores
do grammy latino para escrever uma letra
de uma música que pudesse evidenciar e
valorizar esse sentimento de nós sermos
rockstars da nossa vida e para encerrar
eu gostaria de pedir a vocês que você se
levanta
embora e que vocês se aplaudam porque
vocês são os rockstars da vida de vocês
[Aplausos]